那个我自己的主页里面写到，
女人啊，
一定要做自己的码头，
真的女人要保护好自己啊，
一定要保护好自己，
我现在出门都有点儿不太敢一个人出门了，
我不知道我是不是有点儿受害者妄想症，
还是怎么怎么的，
但是我跟你们聊的都是心里话，
我要出门的时候，
要么就拉着老我老公陪着我，
要么就拉着我们家大侄子陪着我，
我自己一个人都不太敢出门了，
我不瞒你们啊，
我现在每次因为我自己开那个小车，
车啊就是非常的小巧，
我有的时候自己一个人出门，
比如说我要去洗个头啊，
我要去买点什么东西啊，
我自己一个人出门的时候，
我上车第一眼先看一下后座有没有人，
你知道吧，
就是上车之前我先嗯看一下后座有没有人，
我是怕后座有个人在那想绑架我，
就这那的，
然后我上车第一件事情我就是锁车门，
我没有骗你们啊，
这是我的生活习惯，
我也不想制造什么恐慌，
但是我希望就是经常听龙飞姐的姐妹们也养成好的生活习惯，
或你自己一个人啊，
开车的话，
你去了那个地下停车场，
你第一件事情你先撒问一下周围有没有可疑的人，
第二件事情你先看一下你的汽车的后座有没有人在那潜伏着，
第三件事情就是你上车第一件事情先锁车门好不好，
嗯，
我飞姐我不想说制造恐慌也不好，
但是我们养。
很好的习惯，
它没有坏处，
尤其是家里要是有了小孩儿，
小孩一上车的话，
一定要落那个儿童锁，
你你当这些东西你形成一种肌肉记忆了，
它变成你的一种肌肉记忆了之后，
它确实会增加安全系数，
减少很多可能的风险嘛，
是吧，
但凡是出门，
如果我要打车去哪一个地方的话，
我一定是要在家里面的群里，
在家里面的群里一定要告诉他我，
比如说我去弄个眉毛，
我一定告诉他我在哪个哪个眉毛的店啊，
我去我大概要弄多少时间，
大概要弄一个小时，
或者要弄一个半小时，
比如我要去哪个店，
我要去，
比如说弄一下皮肤啊，
我一定会加在家里面的群里，
说我要去哪个地方的哪个店，
地址在哪里，
我去弄我的皮肤，
我大概多久能回来，
就一定女孩子就是养成这样的习惯了之后，
就是对伴侣来说的话也是一个好事儿，
就伴侣他会也会有安全感，
说哎，
我媳妇儿去哪了？
知道跟我报备一下啊，
知道跟我说一下啊，
怕我担心啊什么的，
就是大家女孩子出门吧，
一定要以最大的恶意去测陌生人，
呃，
包括现在教孩子也是一定要以最大的恶意去揣测陌生人，
不管是哪个陌生人说问你们家小孩借。
点什么东西让你们家小孩儿帮忙带，
点什么东西让你们家小孩儿帮忙带路啊，
干嘛干嘛的，
就是要教会他以最大的恶意去揣测陌生人。